[Music]
i see a striking similarity between
music and code
[Music]
when you're producing music or when
you're making music that product that
you're making is a stream of bits it's
ones and zeros and every single action
you take every stroke of the guitar
every conversation you have in the
studio affects how those bits come out
i'm doing two things that i really love
to do and i think that they fuel each
other
my name is brandon tory i'm a musician
and a senior engineer at google working
on ai
as a teenager i lived in a homeless
shelter i met a lot of kids from that
walk of life
i grew up a couple blocks down from
where there was a lot of drug activity
and things like that and a lot of my
friends went to that so obviously that
was a challenge i was like man i want to
get into music i want to do these other
things
when i was living in this shelter one of
the things i brought with me was this
computer that i had built from parts
that i found around the neighborhood and
i spray painted it black and one of the
things i was doing was coding i started
to live this double life where i was
working as an engineer and then i would
come back put out music and do these
things and trying to balance my life as
an artist and my life as an engineer
separately
once again i want to thank everybody for
coming out tonight i'm gonna play the
records for you guys i'm not expecting
you to stand still you know let's have a
good time i appreciate you guys thank
you
first time i played music it felt like
you get this sense of understanding
[Music]
and so what happens is you start to rap
you get in these freestyle ciphers or
these battles or these music sessions
and everybody's really just exchanging
their story and you start to realize
we're really not that different and
music just made it feel very very
obvious and very very powerful me and
benny got a joke when he showed me
diamond chains she gonna take forever
shipping i'm gonna take forever pain
first six months a minute late a friend
of mine said hey man this is contest
with timberland i think you should enter
it and so i just entered it and then one
day i got a call i picked up my phone in
this timber
timberland is arguably the best producer
of all time right next to dr dre and
some of the other legends and for me
that just felt like such a breakthrough
i think all independent artists could
relate to that because we all take this
risk and this and this jump to say man
we want to be creative we want to create
our art and you go through this grind
period where you just don't know if
you're even making any progress at all
and so to have tim call me and say man i
love what you're doing that gave me this
huge surge of energy to keep fighting
and to keep creating
[Music]
my long-term goal will always be to be a
creator
[Music]
all dreams and all things that you're
trying to accomplish have certain
qualities in common you're trying to
constantly create something from nothing
and whether or not that involves coding
or music or any of the tools at my
disposal i'm willing to use those to
create better experiences
[Music]